hi how are you hi Sophie thank you okay
so after all of that commotion all of
that business
thank you I'm wearing I forgot to worry
my story
Mon story he won vogue Arabia's number
one designer and he worked with my body
and I feel amazing I watched you do a
princess look but not only that I had
Karl Lagerfeld and Jeremy Scott and Miss
keno and Christian Siriano and Michael
Costello like all send me stuff and that
was like that was really awesome to me
and I didn't expect that
so my sides a TAS is here on the red
carpet
anyway absolutely slaying that's an
understatement if that had feels so
amazing to get this groundswell of
support after you know it's hard it's
hard it's hard cause it's like so flub
is a really tough thing and like I think
that them like they're they're paving
the way you know to me it and I thought
that was really that made me really
emotional well tell me a secret about
this the secret of this dress is so
poufy that I can have a burger and I can
eat and you won't see now we've been
asking artists to give us questions to
ask other artists so artisan artists
here and the question I got was from
Camilla Kibeho and she wanted to know
what is your cutoff for eating before a
performance because if you cut it too
close it gets a little dicey yeah about
two hours before dinars that's what she
yeah two hours before we had the same
vocal coach that's why now what is one
thing you've always wanted to ask
another celeb and I'll ask it to the
next person have you ever farted on
stage getting real with it yeah really
when she said that question she's like
you can get a little Burpee yes exactly
like sometimes I'll be on stage well and
I ate too close I'm like I'm like oh no
now I have to talk about meant to be for
a second I love the FGL guys I've known
them for years love this song it's been
so great to see you all three have such
a moment together and I understand
some came together what they were
supposed to have a right with someone
else that day is that right with Charlie
puth yeah and then you came in the room
yeah
and magic happens yeah I think that
something happened with Charlie's
schedule where he couldn't make it and
they called me in last minute and I went
in and we wrote the song and it was like
it was meant to be his corneas I always
say that but it really was meant to be
absolutely so how has it been kind of
sharing this experience with them it's
amazing it's like having two brothers
and like you're never alone and you
don't ever be scared and you just I
always have them and it's that's really
nice
[Music]